Monday night Rachel search for love is
getting down and dirty ladies hair is a
force that can't be recognized I don't
know what kind of hair products he is
using today but he needs to patent it
the masterminds behind what may be the
dirtiest date in show history are
Rachel's bachelor besties Corinne Raven
Alexis and jasmine know how they get to
wear anti mud gear but the rest of the
audience does it hmm Monday night's
other group date sticks with the show
the guys shirtless theme when Rachel and
six contestants go on Ellen and strip
down Magic Mike style
if this looks familiar well it's because
the day already aired on Ellen back in
March yeah this season producers are
okay with some leaked secrets hey Rachel
even announced she's engaged certainly a
big no-no in the past so what's behind
ABC spoiler strategy you've gone to tell
everybody the world that you're engaged
like did you ask the producer were you
like a hack to tell people I think it
was kind of mutual like I'm saying it
they're like you know what just do it
cuz I think a lot of people will be more
invested to know this worked for her you
know she so was not a believer hopeful
but it actually happened and I think
people will really like tap into that
[Music]